mais d'abord Lucas dans le loircher le
préfet annonce que plus aucun enfant ne
dort à la rue dans le département ou
relien quelques jours après la forte
mobilisation du collectif pas d'enfants
à la rue 41 le préfet du département
explique avoir accédé à la demande des
familles sans domicile fixe depuis lundi
tous les enfants qui dormaient dans les
rues notamment blaisoise ont été relogés
dans des hôtels une solution temporaire
pas viable selon le collectif et qui
laisse craindre un retour prochain à la
situation initiale hélè chapelet 7
degrés affiché ce matin sur cette
pharmacie blaisoise les cheminées
fonctionnent à nouveau et les bonnets
sont sortis difficile d'imaginer que des
familles avec enfants puissent encore
dormir dehors selon le préfet du
loircher ce n'est plus le cas les
capacités d'hébergement d'urgence ont
été revu à la hausse 310 places
désormais avec de nouvelles chambres
réservées à l'hôtel mettre en place des
dispositif d'accueil d'urgence ça
nécessite d'identifier les lieux de
trouver les financements et et d'être en
capacité d'accueillir correctement alors
on le fait dès maintenant he puisque
depuis hier soir nous ne laissons plus
personne dans la rue et sur toute la
période hivernale le dispositif sera
opérationnel et mise en œuvre sans qu'il
n'y ait de difficultés il y a 10 jours
500 personnes se retrouvaient devant la
préfecture à l'appel du nouveau
collectif Blaisois pas d'enfant à la rue
à l'époque on parlait d'une trentaine
d'enfants sans toit pour la nuit
aujourd'hui selon le collectif même si
les familles et les enfants sont bien
pris en charge il ne le serait que
jusqu'au 12 décembre les hôtels on les
connaît dans lesquels ils sont hébergés
il n'y a pas de possibilité de cuisiner
il n'y a pas de possibilité de prendre
le petit- dééjeuner ce sont des hôtels
qui sont à au moins trois qu4s d'heure
en bus des lieux de scolarité des
enfants c'est du logement mais qui est
très très précaire alors quelle solution
d'hébergement après la date du 12
décembre le collectif restera vigilant
il précise également qu'il vient
toujours en a à une dizaine d'enfants et
à leurs proches mis à l'abri grâce à la
mobilisation de ses
membres